they let us onto the ride and you know
there's a pre-show with explain what's
happening in the world of Pandora it's
been a hundred years since the movie
ended so all those people are dead
that's why Sigourney Weaver don't show
up or anything too expensive
yeah so they tell you the back story
they're gonna hook you into an avatar
like you do in the movie and [ __ ] and
then you're gonna go explore how pandora
has restored itself so you've waited on
this line where they give you the
backstory and then they open up doors
and they say okay one through eight go
here eight nine through sixteen go here
they bring into a room and it's got what
looked like kind of like motorcycles
like lined up next to each other and so
they tell you to like how to get on it
they like put one leg over at a time I'm
like I've been on a [ __ ] bike like so
you get on it and they're like scoot up
as much as you can you scoot up forward
and then this thing comes out the back
and pushes out you forward and locks you
in place that's their version of a seat
belt or something like that so you put
on these [ __ ] goggles and you know
then there's like a light show they're
like here we go you're about to be
connected to your avatar and mist to
obscure your view and while that's
happened and the wall in front of you
opens to put you into the surround thing
right and I've seen some [ __ ] in this
life you know impressive [ __ ] [ __ ]
like I can't even name it but I've seen
some very impressive things of the
nothing and I've ever created but [ __ ]
that I've seen I guess I saw my kid get
born that was pretty [ __ ] amazing
this was better this was like weren't
you on a bicycle with goggles on when
your kid was born no not cool and she
came out goofy and route
this was a movie and it was like five
minutes long the ride dude like my mom
again 71 she never really goes on rides
or anything but we brought her and stuff
so she got on as well and the she had
like the second-best review of the ride
as soon as it began they bring you in to
Pandora it's this [ __ ] beautiful
landscape and then you're on the back of
a Banshee the things that you know you
trained to fly and you fight the other
the big bird not big bird from Sesame
Street but the big bird that he fought
in the movie their hair burned have it
suck learn your numbers [ __ ] and
they fought
so use your fly throughout you go
through the forest you smell pine trees
and [ __ ] like that you go toward the
ocean it splashes water on you see these
big like sharks whales the combos like
jump up and [ __ ] splash it is
breathtaking like and and because it's
so new and people haven't like thrown
[ __ ] at the screen or whatever like it
really feels pretty like immersive like
you're in the [ __ ] [ __ ] how stoned
were you can i super [ __ ] stuff gonna
help but my mother's review like take me
out of the equation my mom's review is
legit it opens up and you're in [ __ ]
Pandora and all I can hear from my left
is my mom goes Wow and that's like a 71
year old woman's version of I'm coming
so hard give me a towel oh you know so
your mom's doing her Owen Wilson
impression it was [ __ ] astounding
dude but like it takes you it's five
minutes not even [ __ ] fast so you
like really get to feel it and and the
things that you're locked into like your
legs get locked into them as well this
thing you're sitting on so it feels like
whatever you're on is breathing oh
that's gonna call it's [ __ ] dopest
[ __ ] man but at the end it ends with
this insane Pantera panorama of like the
Pandora Oceanside and these two [ __ ]
whales pop out and [ __ ] flying blue cats
everywhere it's amazing and then all of
a sudden it's like you know avatar
action breaking and the lights all start
blinking in [ __ ] and screen goes dark as
the two walls close and the ride is over
and this is what I heard the [ __ ]
best review man I was sitting here my
mom was sitting here right and there was
a kid nine ten years old sitting next to
my mom and so as soon as the ride ends
man this was this is what the [ __ ]
kids was his review wall [ __ ] closes
he goes it was astounding it's
definitely worth [ __ ] checking out
some people on I put it up on social
media and some people like you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] for Disney I'm a [ __ ] for
anything that's like that entertaining
I'll suck the dick of anything that like
makes me feel like a child again I know
now that analogy is weird but you know
[ __ ] well I hope to make you feel like
that's your task it yeah but that was
Florida it was pretty amazing if you get
down there if you get a chance check out
that avatar ride not the one on the boat
[ __ ] that unless you're looking to get a
[ __ ] go to the [ __ ] one where
you're on the birds back there
[ __ ] amazed well we're gonna be down
there in the September yeah that's right
we're going down a you know Orlando do
show hard rock yeah you got to go on it
with come on let's do it
you
[Music]